[Music]
why do you have so many metals there oh
yes well in Bolivia where you receive a
medal for every pound moon all right for
god sakes well wait a minute then why
doesn't she have any medals count and
please in believe AG why women don't
have bowel movements oh oh oh dammit
what's wrong I
[Music]
fried cheese balls today say you just
hate yourself
so yesterday someone's at the wall
interrupted the show to [ __ ] the wall
and then today someone interrupts the
show day at their fans after a tell yes
del Taco del flush oh every flush tells
Del Taco your body just made room for
uno mas
you mean all I have to do is whoa and
the more you use it the more del tacos
del flush oh perfects it's intuition
anticipating your body needs and
gradually reducing the lag time between
delivery
consumption
and elimination until your body and Del
Taco achieve a perfect synchronized loop
which we call del Finity I think
dressing up in tuxes is a little
presumptuous guys it was funny but
please what if it hadn't done well oh my
god I so wish that it bombed I so wish
that it Vons yeah it just keeps going
and going and going
ah oh my god
what could possibly top that
[Applause]
don't worry boss I'll sell it real good
hey look it's Jordan hi Jordan
always walking in after the hard work is
over well you try looking at all you try
destroying evidence all morning it's
hard when you murder every night all
right I'm ready I'm not waiting on
anybody
[Music]
yeah it Smitty
[Applause]
[Music]
hey wait hold it hey yeah yeah it's not
amazing to compete with him he ain't a
baby yeah with my sperm yeah you shot it
into a lady
yeah and she's that's how it works
Oh stork no magic muffin yeah magic
yeah then put a Katie Katie
[Laughter]
[Music]
you